parfois je fais des rêves vraiment très
bizarres je vois des choses qui vont se
produire et je me réveille la peur au
ventre
le désespoir la mort la destruction
la seconde crise alors encore plus grave
que celle que tu as affronté
[Musique]
un empire respire non pas de l'air mais
tu respectes car il en a besoin pour
vivre la fondation de menace directement
virer là-bas et je reprendrai ce qui
nous appartient
pour que chacun de nous survivent nous
devons les affronter on va devoir se
battre
nous cherchons la paix
pas parce que nous avons peur d'être
vaincu
[Musique]
mais parce que nous savons
si guérilla
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous prenons le contrôle de cette
planète
toi et moi devons avoir une conversation